what's up gamers if you're a fan of the
stormlight archive you're probably
wondering what's the best clean water
infrastructure for your city if you love
that scene where caledon does the thing
with the spear then you will love the
james w jardine water purification plant
in chicago illinois the plant treats 1.4
billion gallons per day designed and
built by chicago's bureau of engineering
the plant began operating in 1964. if
you loved shalon in that sea then the
scene was the girl boss shalon and
you love the general san martin water
processing plant in buenos aires uh
argentina
i don't know sometimes i wonder if you
really care about water filtration the
brandon sanderson fandom cosmere fandom
and the water treatment fandom are not
always
in good terms i
want to make videos that are true to who
i am and i feel like i can't do that
if i'm not
also talking about water treatment
services
in major industrial cities
i'm doing the best i can okay and if my
heart wants to compare dalinar to the
f98 water filtration pump built in 1940
then
i will do that i will find a way thank
you to my patrons who
are just loyal through it all they are
the real heroes don't forget to change
your brita filter right you need to do
it more often than you think so please
take care of that
best best of luck to you all